hey there is there a project you're
working on
i know more than you all right
what is going on guess what i have flaws
what are they oh i don't know i sing in
the shower
sometimes i spend too much time
volunteering occasionally i'll hit
somebody with my car
so sue me guess why my thumbs are up no
i feel i should remind you that i do not
believe that the position
or the entire government should exist i
mean i have so many ideas
some are simple like take down traffic
lights and
eliminate the post office the bigger
ones will be tougher
like bring all of this crumbling to the
ground
and i'll have the number eight that's a
party platter it serves 12 people
i know what i'm about son someone will
die
of fun these are the black eyed peas
and i finally killed them
it's a christmas miracle my mom's puerto
rican
that's why i'm so lively and colorful
um i hooked your toilet up to your
shower that's what you wanted right
yes excellent and they would never
cancel game of thrones
it's a crossover hit it's not just for
fantasy enthusiasts
they're telling human stories in a
fantasy world
do you see him do you think a depressed
person could make this
[Music]
no
[Applause]
waffles and then we're staying up all
night talking about our lives and our
feelings
non-negotiable let's go city council
[ __ ]
jerry forgot to vote
[Music]
you